a photo can capture any moment in a
fraction of a second it gives us the
chance to see things we would have
missed if we blinked and sometimes we
just see things in a new perspective
this is how we end up with hilarious
pictures that will last forever are you
ready to see the results wait until you
see the woman who seems to be playing
with a miniature human at the beach if
this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you 20 photos that
were perfectly timed the stork bird if
your parents ever tell you that starts
to livered babies when you were a kid
this theory never made sense even though
we would never dare to question them but
now they can show you the proof that
they were right look at this baby
falling from the sky in the arms of his
father we thought that this bird's
delivery would be a little smoother most
of us thought about finding a baby at
our doorstep and not randomly catching
one when we didn't expect it but it
seems like we were all really lucky to
have the best father to catch us this
super eagle do you know why the national
animal of the United States of the bald
eagle no it is not because Americans are
losing their hair it is because of its
long life great strength and majestic
look if you want to see how powerful the
bald eagle is just take a look at this
picture it appears to fly so fast that
it leaves a white trail behind it just
like an airplane and eagles truly are
incredibly skilled with a wingspan of 6
to 8 feet they can dive at up to 100
miles per hour but this bird's greatest
power is certainly its freedom and
liberty in the sky we couldn't think of
a better animal to represent the United
States of America than the king of the
birds the tall giraffe this animal is
known for its really long neck but do
you know how tall it can be if you take
a look at this picture you could believe
that this giraffe is tall enough to
touch a plane we bet the people in the
plane were surprised by the view when
they looked out the window we just hope
that the animal didn't cause the plane
to crash it would be hard for the pilot
to explain this story but let's be
serious even if it doesn't touch the sky
the draft is still the tallest land
animal alive it can be up to 18
feet tall the jumping dog we all know
that looking at a cute dog can make our
day no matter what they do they will
always find a way to make a smile even
if we're having a bad day when we think
that we have seen everything this dog is
here to surprise us just look at this
strange creature is it a mop with eyes
or maybe it's a dog with no legs what
you are looking at is a dog breed called
the Puli it is easily recognizable but
it's long corded coat similar to
dreadlocks but what we love the most
about this unique dog is it seems to
have so much fun jumping the hidden cat
cats love to play and they are so fun to
watch but this time you won't be able to
see the feline it is playing hide and
seek can you see it yes this game was
easier than we would have thought we
have to admit this cat didn't find the
best place to hide with the picture on
the frame it looks like we can see the
whole animal
but this cat had a good plan he tried to
escape in the 2-dimensional world
unfortunately it forgot its tail outside
this parallel universe and its owner
easily found it is there any weird place
where your cat likes to hide don't
forget to tell us in the comments we
would love to hear from you the cyclist
we all smile when we look at pictures of
the countries we visited but this
tourist can make anyone laugh by showing
them this funny picture well this man
was posing in front of the Vienna State
Opera a cyclist came out of nowhere to
photobomb his picture actually we could
guess he probably didn't mean to do this
if we take a look at this photo he just
drove his bike straight into the pole
the tourists didn't even realize what
was happening while he was posing we
just hope that the cyclist was okay
after that incident and then he had the
chance to see this photo online laughter
is the best medicine
after all the falling lady you remember
the time when your parents asked you not
to run or stay too close to the pool
there was a reason for that and this
woman learned it the hard way once again
a man who is just trying to casually
pose for a photo when a woman in the
background stole the show she was just
about to fall into the pool with her
clothes
but the funniest thing about this
picture is that neither the man the
woman or her friends realized it when
this picture was taken she was just at a
weird angle
and not ready for what was going to
happen less than a second after the
breakdance Jesus used to turn water into
wine and walk on water thousands of
years ago but now that we're in the 21st
century he found another way to impress
his disciples the Christ is now
breakdancing on the water just look at
this man showing off his skills on a
lake we bet that his father is watching
these impressive dance moves from the
sky but there's one thing we are
thinking about why isn't he sharing a
message of love even though he has
secretly been on earth for so many years
let's give him a break the Son of God
can take some time to have fun too the
perfect selfie we all love taking
pictures of ourselves but some people
wanted to take it to the next level they
didn't want to be admired for their
looks but for their sweet skills this is
why the new trend is now taking a selfie
while high-fiving yourself how is that
even possible just take a look at those
who already succeeded to see how it
works
you need to use the timer drop your
phone at the right moment and clap your
hands as fast as possible many people
tried it and hilariously failed but this
is what makes this picture even more
perfectly timed the last drink
we know that alcohol is bad for our
health but most of us drink anyway
however this time the universe wanted to
protect two friends by making sure they
wouldn't be able to take a sip of their
beer just look at what happened
the man's glass broke into pieces and
the beer spilled everywhere this poor
woman was probably so disgusted that she
went straight to the bathroom and didn't
want to drink her beer when she came
back at least what could have been a
disastrous dinner turned out to be an
incredible story to tell with this
picture the smallest soldiers things
that are far away from us look so small
compared to what is right next to us who
mix the two together we get incredible
results this soldier had one great idea
in mind when he took this picture he
made sure he was perfectly timed when
other soldiers came off the helicopter
from this perspective it looks like they
are falling directly into his mouth or
maybe this is a new tactic to get rid of
his enemies
by eating them the flying president have
you ever heard about the theory that
Barack Obama is not American some people
believe that he was born in Kenya so he
was not eligible to be President of the
United States and even though Obama
published his birth certificate it
wasn't enough to make them stop but now
we know that Obama is not American he
comes from an Arabian country just look
at him flying on a magic carpet just
like Aladdin did when we take a closer
look at this picture we understand that
there is simply a shadow on the ground
next to the carpet but it is still fun
to imagine that being the president of
the United States comes with the ability
to fly the highest jump how high can you
jump most people can jump higher than a
few inches above the ground this is why
you will be impressed to see that this
man can do a front flip over a plane we
have the photo to prove it okay he might
not be able to jump a hundred feet above
the ground but do you know how high a
man can jump the world record for the
highest jump without using any kind of
assistance is more than 8 feet high this
person would be able to jump over
another human being even though this is
probably not what happened in this
perfectly timed picture we can still be
impressed by his awesome skills the
giant seagull we have heard about giant
gorillas like King Kong and giant
monsters like Godzilla invading the city
but who thought that we would one day
have to face enormous seagulls you can
see one of these specimens in this
picture a man was walking right next to
it and he didn't even seem to notice
what was happening or maybe he was
simply paralyzed by fear
at least these birds don't seem too
dangerous they might want to steal our
french fries but that is not the worst
thing that could happen we are ready for
the day that giant seagulls will take
over the world
the tiny woman the beach is one of the
best places to go to have fun with our
friends we love to swim make sandcastles
or simply relax and sunbathe everyone
can do any activity they like even when
there are tiny human beings just look at
this woman playing with her friend there
looking at this picture we might think
of this beach goer is helping her tiny
friend jump in the air or maybe the
woman sitting on the
each is a giant and the one who's
jumping is as tall as we are we have to
think about it for a second understand
that they are actually really far away
from each other and even if they are
giant tiny or simply normal we'd love to
see friends having fun on the beach the
runner winning a race is difficult
you're competing with great runners and
sometimes milliseconds make all the
difference
but this man thought that this
competition was not hard enough for him
this is why he decided to run on his
hands unfortunately the other runners
weren't interested in this idea and
decided to stand on their feet but no
matter what we can admire the courage of
the runner who is now upside down in
this picture even though he probably
didn't mean to be in this position right
now he got back up on his feet and never
gave up the figure skater figure skaters
always impress us with their acrobatic
moves we keep falling when we're
standing on our two feet on the ground
we can't even imagine what it would be
like to do these acrobatic moves while
standing on one foot on ice but this
time these athletes surprised us in the
weirdest way a woman coming out of a
man's bottom is not something we
expected to see at this competition this
real move they were trying to do is
probably gorgeous but when we look at it
from this point of view we can't help
but laugh these two figure skaters at
least deserve a medal for their
creativity the swimmer we are so
captivated by the speed of these
swimmers that we don't even pay
attention to what they look like but
when we take the time to capture this
moment were fascinated by these pictures
this is Olympic swimmer Tyler Clary just
before he breaks out of the water and he
is not the only backstroker who looks
like that when he's emerging from the
water with all this tension on the
surface it looks like they're back in
the womb we just hope that they still
had time to breathe and win that
competition and the photographer
deserves a medal too the headless player
we are always impressed by football
players strength you have to be tough to
play that kind of a sport and also have
the right equipment to protect yourself
but now we understand the real reason
why these athletes wear a helmet it is
not to protect their head it is to make
sure it stays on their shoulder just
look at what happened when this play
fell he didn't only lose his helmet but
his head came off too we know there's a
head hiding somewhere on this man's body
but we just can't see it or maybe he's
just a turtle hiding his head in his
shell when he's afraid we would
understand him
football is a dangerous sport the
gymnasts
we are always impressed by gymnast their
bodies are so flexible that they seem to
be made of rubber they are stronger than
anyone else we know and we admire their
courage they have to do backflips but
what surprised us the most was to see
that a woman was able to do this even if
she had a foot on her shoulder is
difficult to see and to find balance
when you don't have a head but this
young woman became a gymnast anyway we
know there's a head somewhere on this
woman's shoulder but we are still
impressed to see that she is so flexible
that we don't even see her head when she
bends over backwards and that's it for
20 photos that were perfectly timed did
any of them make you smile if so don't
forget to like this video and subscribe
to our Channel and if you just can't get
enough of these photos make sure you
watch ten pictures taken at the perfect
moment thank you so much for watching
bye bye
[Music]